and finally new roles someone has to
explain if our economy is doing so great
how come everyone is broke to me the
real lesson of this government shutdown
is that we found out that federal
workers quintessential middle class jobs
can't afford to miss one paycheck I must
have seen a hundred stories about
furloughed workers that look like this I
literally don't know how I'm gonna
provide for my kids furloughed interior
worker Malorie lorg rationing her
insulin first off I can't pay my
mortgage I guess this is what Fox means
by getting tired of winning when did it
get this desperate one day you're a
lineman for the county you miss a payday
and you're ratso Rizzo making coffee in
a saucepan this shutdown is not about
the wall it's about the wallet and it's
more proof that the great American
middle class is disappearing faster than
our Kelley's Facebook friends
Oh
that is the story here that our economy
no longer creates a middle class it
sucks it dry oh thank you all middle
class means now is that you're poor but
you don't do meth and remember this is
the good economy where 40% of Americans
can't afford a $400 emergency expense
and 15 million have nothing saved for
retirement sorry but it's not middle
class when your retirement plan is a
lotto ticket when I was a kid being a
middle class family meant only one
breadwinner two cars a vacation and a
paneled basement that smelled like
cigarettes College was affordable
getting sick didn't mean going bankrupt
I can go out to dinner once a week you
could have a dog and when he got older
your parents could afford to send him to
live on a farm where he was happier
[Applause]
but little by little the middle-class
got squeezed now middle-class means two
breadwinners and one car and the only
reason your daughter can afford college
at all is sugar daddy's calm vulture
capitalism has done to our middle class
what the airlines did to their customers
because we didn't lose the comforts of
being middle class all at once they took
it away from us an inch at a time like
legroom back in the day flying was a joy
the seats were roomy the chicken looked
like something that was once a chicken
and the bathrooms were large enough to
enjoy the mile-high club
contrast that with today where there's
first class business class premium
economy economy and [ __ ] you
[Music]
this was coach as recently as the 90s
here it is now I remember so vividly I
was 37 when I throw up when I flew first
class for the first time and it blew my
mind they were literally carving a roast
in the cart in the aisle like it was
friggin Thanksgiving up there now your
food comes in a box it used to get good
stuff on a plane a meal drunk the seat
and funnier could recline without
starting a fistfight and just like with
the economy writ large they squeezed
incrementally though first they took
away the pillows then the free booze the
free headset free luggage allowance
legroom the whole can of coke the
blankets blankets putting an end to in
flight masturbation
days without flying it but on the upside
the flight safety films are funny now
so porn parodies have something to look
down on but here's the thing about
squeezing people and keeping them
insecure it virtually ensures that our
long-term major problems never get fixed
because reducing the debt or repairing
our infrastructure or most importantly
halting climate change requires
long-term thinking which is something
you can't really do when the wolf is
always at the door Bangladesh will be
underwater in 20 years I'm underwater
today Whole Foods I just want to get
some food in my hole and that's just how
the Koch brothers like it to have people
so caught up in today's problems we
never have time for tomorrow's
you